un sommet du g7 placée sous le signe de
la vaccination contre le commis de 19
pour deux jours le groupe des sept
dirigeants des pays au monde les plus
développés se retrouva carbis b au
royaume uni emmanuel macron s'est
exprimée par le biais d'une conférence
de presse jeudi et a rappelé l'objectif
principal de ce g7 la vaccination pour
tous ce g7 est un moment de ré
engagement collectif et clarification je
me méfie des objectifs quand il s'agit
d'additionner des milliards sans
calendrier précis et résultats à
atteindre
il nous faut viser avant tout une cible
de pourcentage de la population à
vacciner 60 % d'africains à vacciner
d'ici la fin du premier trimestre 2009
en deux avec un objectif de 40% pour fin
de l'année 2021 joe biden a d'ailleurs
annoncé l'achat de 500 millions de doses
de vaccins qui seront distribués à près
de 100 pays
le président américain évoque une étape
historique premières réunions physiques
du g7 depuis la pandémie le coc vide et
première pour joe biden depuis son
élection à la maison blanche en novembre
dernier
joe biden a d'ores et déjà annoncé la
couleur de ses interventions à venir
avec ses homologues étrangers notamment
pour sa rencontre très attendue avec
vladimir poutine le 16 juin prochain je
lève je vais me rendre à genève pour
passer du temps avec un homme avec qui
j'ai déjà passé du temps vladimir
poutine nous ne cherchons pas le conflit
avec la russie
nous voulons une relation stable et
prévisible nous donation-partage
d'incroyables responsabilités et parmi
elles celle d'assurer la stabilité
stratégique en faisant respecter les
accords de contrôle des armements
au programme des discussions du g7 la
gestion de la pandémie la taxation des
géants du numérique ou encore le
financement de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
c'est donc un sommet du g7 très scrutées
où les rencontres entre jobs hayden et
ses homologues s'annonce d'ores et déjà
décisive dans les futures relations
internationales du monde d'après commis